Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is my
house the dragon deleted scene video first ones
that we know so far during the series and there
are about four deleted scenes so i'll explain
all them during this video if you're brand new to
the channel i'm doing videos for all the episodes
just like i did for game of thrones be sure to
subscribe to get them all i'll do the deleted
scenes in chronological order starting with the
scene of rhaenyra's immediate reaction to allison
hightower getting engaged to her father viserys
targaryen there was a huge time jump between
episode 2 and episode 3 and at the beginning of
the cut that we actually saw viserys had already
been married to alicent for a couple years and
her first son with him aegon ii is having his
second birthday so like a lot of time has gone by
in this first deleted scene rhaenyra meets alicent
right after the engagement is announced before
the wedding ceremony in the godswood here they
keep using this as a big location in the episodes
keep going back here mythologically it's also
one of the biggest connections that they have to
the game of thrones series in the weirwood trees
the three-eyed raven the children of the forest
the night king the white walkers the long night
so it makes sense that they would keep going back
to the weirwood here we'll probably do it again
several times this season and the scene would have
had renera yelling at alison about how much of a
betrayal it felt like like you kind of get that
moment after the engagement is announced but you
don't actually get a scene between the two of them
till well after her first child has been born they
were meant to be best friends before that if
this wasn't clear like the actresses also said
that they had been playing their relationship as
if they were also kind of secretly in love like
the connection had a romantic component to it but
it wasn't as overtly sexual as you would normally
think for a show like game of thrones given what
we just saw happen in episode 4. given all that
sister wiving and twin sets we see happening
all over the place both of the actresses said
that that wasn't on the page like their romantic
relationship before things get really awkward with
the events of the show it was just something that
they chose to do on their own like they made it
feel like more of a romantic connection between
the two of them and some of that would have come
out during this scene metaphorically and literally
make all the jokes that you want about that
and they would have made it clear during this
deleted scene that allison didn't want to marry
her father she was just kind of forced to do it
but as you see in later episodes allison as a
character just feels like she needs to follow the
rules do whatever everyone tells her to do so she
does whatever her father says to do even if she
doesn't really want to do it which is part of
the reason why she gets so pissed off at renera
when she finds out about what she's been up to in
flea bottom with damon targaryen so if it wasn't
clear allison didn't actually want to get married
to her father she liked the attention that she
was getting with the king like she thought that
she was special because the attention like oh
someone's paying attention to me this is great but
it was viserys who just kind of on the spot was
like guess what you're marrying me and she's like
wait what so even though she wasn't completely
innocent in all this she was much more innocent
than you might have thought like she wasn't
trying to betray her friend renera the second
deleted scene was the actual marriage ceremony of
allison hightower and viserys targaryen a little
while later in the timeline they actually filmed
the wedding this is what allison's wedding dress
would have looked like it's a very targaryen
themed dress done in white and red instead
of black and red all the costumes on house the
dragon and game of thrones are fantastic they
must have spent so much money filming this scene
to cut it we haven't seen many actual weddings in
the game of thrones universe they've all gone
terribly the red wedding the purple wedding
sansa's forced wedding to ramsay bolton i'm
assuming that it's common for highborn ladies
in westeros to wear white to weddings though and
during the larger wedding scene they actually
filmed rhaenyra helping alison get dressed in her
gown in their ritual like the dressing was meant
to be a parallel for alison helping rhaenyra
do the same thing getting dressed when she
was preparing to be named the heir earlier in the
series and have all the lords of the realm swear
fealty to her so it was meant to be like this very
personal moment with them together right before
alison got married to her father it would have
shown how close they were despite what had just
happened between the two of them with the betrayal
and her getting engaged to her father we see how
the dynamic between the two of them changes over
the first half of the season going from friends
to then less than friends like things cooling
off to outright frenemies by the end of episode
four heading into episode five and even though
she's accusing renera of sleeping with damon and
getting really pissed at her sounding like she's
disgusted by the target and practice of sister
wiving like you targaryens have queer customs
that's not exactly why she's pissed at rhaenyra
like even though at this moment there's a distance
between them emotionally things have cooled
alison is still desperate for her friendship like
she talks to her about wanting friends nobody's
really friends with me anymore now than the queen
i'm too powerful for people to be friends with
and it's the same thing kind of for renier like
she also feels very much alone in her station even
though she's one of the most powerful people in
the realm as the heir apparent at least on paper
both of them have kind of become prisoners in
their highborne stations although allison at this
point later in the timeline is meant to come off
as being a little bit more of a prisoner as the
queen than renera is which is exactly why she's
so mad at renera for allegedly sleeping around
and breaking all these rules in all her scenes
with viserys and earlier she has this very far
away look in her eyes like she talks about what
her life is like right now what it's turned into
she's got these dead eyes like she's screaming
silently and she's got all this resentment for
rhaenyra because she thinks that she's just doing
whatever she feels like who cares about the rules
but because allison is the queen her behavior is
watched and restricted way more than like a common
slave's behavior like the commenters that you see
in flea bottom are much freer to do whatever they
want to than these two women are particularly
allison so it's moments like this where you
see things cool off between the two of them like
there's a little more resentment building between
the two of them for those reasons that eventually
pushes them closer to the actual dance of the
dragons the blacks versus the greens because in
the episode 5 trailers you see allison wearing the
very infamous green gown that she winds up wearing
through most of the later part of the timeline
during the actual dance of the dragons that's why
they call it the blacks versus the greens because
they're named after the colors of the gowns that
they wear i don't think the actual dance of the
dragons itself will begin until after like the
major time jump when the older versions of the
actresses start playing the characters in episode
six but i think it'll happen well after the events
of episode six like much later in the series even
though i believe episode six is when the older
actresses will take over like episode five is one
of the last times in season one that we'll see the
young versions of the actresses but i believe
they're coming back for season two so what they
might do is just have flashbacks for more context
for their relationship and that's how they bring
the young actresses back the next deleted scene
was after allison and viserys's wedding with him
learning that she was going to give birth to a son
aegon ii and it was meant to be a happy scene like
it was him celebrating that he'd have a son that
would survive the birth he'd had two male children
with emma aaron his first wife ronira's mother
but neither one of them survived long after birth
mostly the blame for that lies on the targaryen
practice of marrying so closely in the family for
so long viserys and damon's parents were brother
and sister and viserys and his first wife emma
were first cousins emma was the daughter of one of
jahaerys many many children they probably decided
to cut that scene just because it was too extra
because you have his reaction at the beginning
of episode three with the second birthday of
aegon the second everybody in the realm is going
crazy over him fawning over him so it's generally
the same type of scene everyone in the realm is
elated that he exists everyone except for rhaenyra
that is the next deleted scene was going to be a
larger introduction for layner valerian in his
lover joffrey lonmuth the person in the episode
5 trailer that you see criston cole just laying
it into during the wedding banquet being named
joffrey at a royal wedding like this just doesn't
seem like a good idea in the game of thrones
universe everybody having joffrey flashbacks to
game of thrones in the purple wedding i think the
idea here was that they were going to do a better
job of setting up laener before rhaenyra meets him
during viserys discussions with cordless valerian
arranging their marriage the whole idea is that
between the two of them neither one wants to get
married rhaenyra is being forced to do it because
of who she is because of this political marriage
that viserys wants to sew up it's also kind of the
fate of all highborn ladies that you're going to
be married off for political reasons but laener
also doesn't want to get married for obvious
reasons because he's gay and his father corlys
also forcing him to do so for the same reasons
that rhaenyra's father is forcing her to do it
for political reasons the way they portray him in
the books is that he's a nice person and he treats
reneira well like he's very cool with everything
but they have an arrangement between the two of
them they have like a very clear understanding
going into the marriage like okay we're going
to make the best of a bad situation we're going to
let each other do whatever we want to do on the dl
so like he continues with his lover joffrey and
she continues doing whatever she wants but they
kind of do it on the sly the thing is though is
that there are very few secrets in westeros like
you have lord of tea over here spilling everyone's
secrets all over the place so that's part of the
reason why things get crazy at the wedding here
because a lot of people's secrets start spilling
out particularly rhaenyra's secrets and what
was going on with the moon tea and criston cole
but the whole thing with rhaenyra and laener is
why there's all these rumors about her first sons
not belonging to laener because the color of their
hair that's why they call them the strong boys
it's all the gossipers in the realm like we saw
during episode three then after the fact they
also clarified what was really going on with
damon when he was with renera in flea bottom
and they were getting it on matt smith explained
during this scene he was actually trying to get
back at his brother like purposefully trying
to rile things up causing a little bit of chaos
messing around with ronira and the reason why he
stopped because he couldn't metaphorically get
it up so to speak is because when they started to
get hot and heavy she actually doubled down on it
got into it and that freaked him out a little bit
and he suddenly realized how crazy what they were
doing was like okay maybe i've gone a little too
far this time and then pumps the brakes and takes
off we'll be talking a lot about the future
of their relationship and the way it develops
because obviously right now she kind of hates
him that isn't going to last for that long but
technically there are a lot of time jumps so even
though it doesn't seem like it lasts that long
it does take place over the course of many
many years as their relationship develops
let's just say it gets more and more complicated
as things go on in the best possible game of
thrones type of way because they film so much
stuff for each episode i'm sure there's going
to be a bunch more deleted scenes for the
rest of the episodes too like this is just
the first half of the season so far so i'll do
more videos as we find out about more of them
my full episode 5 video will post sunday just
like normal i've got a couple big bonus videos
planned so make sure you enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that and big reminder
that the star wars and or episodes are going
to start next week the first three episodes are
gonna start on day one and it is supposed to be
amazing everyone click here for my house of the
dragon episode 5 trailer video and click here
for my full house the dragon episode 4 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!